[MUSIC PLAYING]
KAZ SATO: Thank you.
Thank you for attending
our session, "Android Meets
TensorFlow."
I'm Kaz Sato.
I'm a Developer Advocate for
Google Cloud Platform team,
and--
HAK MATSUDA: Hello.
Good morning.
Thanks for coming in a
very, very early morning.
I'm not a morning person,
so I'm a bit sleepy now.
Anyway, my name
is Hakuro Matsuda.
I am a developer advocate
of Android gaming
and native technology.
KAZ SATO: So today,
in this session,
we'd like to discuss
these topics.
So the first part
of this session,
I will be discussing, what
is AI, machine learning,
neural network,
and deep learning,
and how Google has been using
these kinds of technologies
for implementing our services.
And what is the TensorFlow?
That is an open-source
library for building
your own neural network.
And then, I will pass
the stage to Hak.
He'll be discussing how
you can build the Android
applications powered
by TensorFlow
and how you can optimize it.
And lastly, I'd like
to do a sneak preview
of the new technologies, such
as TensorFlow Lite and Android
neural network API.
So what is machine learning
and neural networks?
How many people actually tried
neural networks by yourselves?
How many people?
Oh, so many people!
Like, 20%?
And how many people have
actually used a neural network
on mobile devices?
Oh, thank you so much.
I found, like, 10 people.
Today, we'd like to learn how
you can use the TensorFlow
and machine learning
module running
inside mobile applications.
There have been
so many buzzwords
such as AI, machine
learning, neural network,
or deep learning.
We have been hearing
about those buzzwords
for the last few years.
What's the difference?
The AI or Artificial
Intelligence-- you can say that
is a science for making
smart things like building
an autonomous
driving car or having
a computer drawing a beautiful
picture or composing music.
And one way to realize
that vision of AI
is in machine learning.
Machine learning is
a technology where
you can let a computer train
itself, rather than having
human programmers
instructing every step,
to process the data by itself.
And one of the many different
algorithms in machine learning
is neural network.
And since around 2012, we have
been seeing a big break-through
in the world of
the neural network,
especially for image
recognition, voice recognition,
or natural language processing
and many other applications.
And at Google, we
have been focusing
on developing the neural network
technologies for several years.
So what is a neural network?
You can think of it just like
a function in mathematics
or a function in
programming language.
So you can put any kind
of data as an input
and do some matrix
operations or calculations
inside neural networks.
Then, eventually, you
would get an output vector
which has the many labels
or speculative values.
For example, if you
have a bunch of images,
you can train the neural
network to classify
which one is the image of a
cat or the image of a dog.
And this is just one
example of the use
cases of neural networks.
You can apply the technology
to solve any kind of business
problems you have.
For example, if you have
a bunch of gaming servers,
then you can try converting all
the user activities, the player
activities, convert them
into a bunch of numbers,
such as vectors, and try
training the neural networks
to classify the type of
players on your gaming server.
For example, if you want to
find any cheating player who
will be using the
automated script to
try to cheat on
your server, or you
can try to use a neural network
to find the premium players who
could be buying more and more
items from your gaming server.
So that is just one
possible example
of the possible thousands
of applications.
At Google, we have been using
deep learning technologies
for implementing the smart
functions on over 100
production projects, including
Google Search, Android, Play,
and many other applications.
For example, if you are using
Google Search every day,
that means you are accessing
the deep learning technologies
provided by Google every day.
Because in 2015, we
introduced RankBrain,
which is a deep learning-based
ranking algorithm that
generates the signals for
the defining and ranking
of the search results.
And if you take a look at
the mobile applications
from Google--
for example, Google
Photos is one
of the most successful
mobile applications that
has been using deep learning
for analyzing and understanding
the content of each image
taken by your smartphones,
so you don't have to put any
tags or keywords by yourself.
Instead, you can just type
dog, your friend's name,
or the wedding party to find the
images based on this content.
Smart Reply is a feature that
shows the options to reply
to each email thread.
So it uses natural
language processing
powered by the
neural network model
to try to understand the
context of the email exchanges.
And now, over 12%
of the responses
are generated by the
Smart Reply features.
So you can say that now, email
has been written by computers
and not by humans anymore.
Google Translate app
recently introduced
a new neural
translation model that
has improved the quality,
especially the fluency,
of the translated
text significantly.
So there are so many
possible use cases
for the combination
between machine learning
and mobile
applications, starting
from image recognition,
OCR, speech-to-text
and text-to-speech,
translation, and NLP.
And especially, you can
apply machine learning
to mobile-specific applications
such as motion detection or GPS
location tracking.
And why do you want
to run your machine
learning model,
your neural network
model inside your
mobile applications?
Because by using the
machine learnings,
you can reduce the
significant amount of traffic,
and you can get much
faster responses
from your Cloud services.
Because you can extract the
meaning from the raw data.
What do I mean by that?
For example, if you are
using machine learning
for image recognition,
the easiest way
to implement that is to
send all the raw image data
taken by the camera
to the server.
But instead, you can have the
machine learning model running
inside your mobile application
so that your mobile application
can recognize what kind of
object is in each image,
so that you can just send
the label, such as flower
or human face, to the server.
That can reduce the
traffic to 1/10 or 1/100.
It's a significant amount
of savings of traffic.
Another example could
be motion detection.
So here, gathering all
the motion, sensory data--
not sending just the raw
images directly to the server,
you can use machine learning
algorithms to extract
the so-called feature vectors.
Feature vector is just
a bunch of numbers,
like 100 or 1,000 numbers that
represent the characteristic
or signature of the motions
from the motion sensors.
So you can just send the
100 or a 1,000 numbers
in the feature
vector to the server.
And what is the
starting point to build
your own mobile application that
is powered by machine learning?
The starting point
could be the TensorFlow,
which is the open-source
library for machine
intelligence from Google.
And TensorFlow is
the latest framework
for building machine learning
or AI-based services developed
in Google.
And we open sourced
it in November 2015.
And now, TensorFlow is
the most popular framework
for building neural networks
or deep learning in the world.
And one benefit you
could get with TensorFlow
is ease of development.
So it's really easy
to get started.
You can just write a few
lines of Python code,
or tens of lines of Python code,
to define your neural network
by yourself.
And actually, this technology
is very valuable for people
like me, because I don't have
any sophisticated mathematical
background.
So when I started reading the
textbook on neural networks,
I found many mathematical
equations on the textbook,
like differentiation,
back propagation,
and gradient descent.
And I really didn't want to
implement everything by myself.
Instead, now, you can
just download TensorFlow,
where you can write a
single line of Python code,
like GradientDescentOptimizer.
That single line of
code can encapsulate
all these obfuscated algorithms
such as gradient descent,
back propagation, or any other
latest algorithms implemented
by the Google engineers.
So you yourself
don't have to have
the skill set to implement
the neural network
technologies from scratch.
Also, the benefits
of the TensorFlow
is the portability
and scalability.
For example, if
you're just getting
started with the technology,
you can download TensorFlow,
only on Mac or
Windows, where you
can play with the Hello World
kind of very simple samples.
But if you are getting serious
about the technologies--
for example, if you want to
render a model from scratch
to recognize the image of a
cat, then you may want to use
the GPU server--
because GPU is,
like, 10 or 50 times
faster than CPU or
Mac or Windows--
to train your model.
But many large companies,
like Google Earth
or any other
enterprises, are using
tens or sometimes hundreds
of GPUs running on the cloud
because the computing
power is the largest
challenge for the deep
learning technologies.
But still, you don't have
to make any major changes
on your TensorFlow
neural networks,
because TensorFlow is
designed to be scalable.
So once you have defined
your neural networks,
you can learn it,
train it, and use it
on a single CPU,
or multiple GPUs,
or hundreds of GPUs, or TPU,
or Tensor Processing Unit,
which is the ASIC or customized
ADSI designed by Google.
And once you have finished
training your model,
you can copy the
model, which has--
for example, for
image recognition,
a single model can
consist of 100 megabytes
of data, the parameters.
You can copy those parameters
to the mobile devices
such as Android,
iOS, or Raspberry Pi.
And if you go to the
TensorFlow.org website,
you can find the sample code
for the embedded systems
and mobile phones.
And then, the benefit you
could get from TensorFlow
is the community and ecosystems.
So if you want to find any
practical production quality
solutions, then the
TensorFlow can provide
the best answer for that.
Because there are so many large
enterprises and developers
who are using TensorFlow
for serious development,
such as Airbus, ARM, eBay,
Intel, Dropbox, and Twitter.
They're all using TensorFlow.
Now, I'd like to pass
the stage to Hak,
who will be talking about how
you can implement the Android
applications powered
by TensorFlow.
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, thank you.
HAK MATSUDA: Thank you, Kazu.
So let's move on to
the Android part.
As Kazu mentioned,
we have found a lot
of great use cases
of running TensorFlow
inference on mobile devices.
Let's take a look at
how we can integrate
TensorFlow inference
on mobile devices
and how we can optimize it.
TensorFlow supports multiple
mobile platforms including
Android, iOS, and Raspberry Pi.
In this talk, we'd like to focus
on mobile devices like Android
and iOS.
Building a TensorFlow
shared object from scratch
was a bit tricky.
It required multiple
steps, starting
from [INAUDIBLE] from GitHub,
installing Bazel, installing
Android Studio,
Android SDK and NDK,
and finally editing a
setting file, et cetera.
But we have good news today.
Announced this IO, we just
added a JSON integration,
which makes those steps
a lot, a lot easier.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, thank you.
Just add one line
to the build Gradle,
and the Gradle takes care
of the rest of steps.
Under the library archive,
[INAUDIBLE] TensorFlow
shared object is
downloaded from JCenter,
linked against the
application automatically.
Also, you can fetch
prebuilt model
files, such as the
inception, stylize,
et cetera, from
the cloud as well.
And it's easier for iOS as well.
We just started a Cocoapod
integration as well.
It's quite simple now.
Let's take a look at how you
can use the TensorFlow API.
We released Android
inference library
to integrate TensorFlow
for Java application.
The library is the
[INAUDIBLE] from Java
to the native implementation.
And the performance
impact is minimal.
At first, create TensorFlow
inference interface,
opening the model file
from the asset in the APK.
Then, set up the input
feed using feed API.
On mobile, the input
feed tends to be
retrieved from various sensors
like a camera, accelerometer,
et cetera.
Then, run the inference.
And finally, you can
fetch the results
using fetch method over there.
You would notice that those
calls are all blocking calls.
So you'd want to run them in
a worker thread, rather than
the main thread, because API
would take a long, long time,
like several seconds.
This one is Java API.
And of course, you can use
regular C++ API as well,
if you love C++ as I do.
OK.
Let's move on to the demo.
This one is a TensorFlow
sample running on Android.
The sample has three modes.
The first one is running
Inception v3 that
classifies the camera image.
And also, we have a classified
face and the stylized photo
sample.
This one is a
stylized photo that
is applying the artistic
filter on the camera preview.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
And one special
thing on the demo
is that I tweaked the demo
a little bit using the GPU,
using [INAUDIBLE]
Compute Shader.
[INAUDIBLE] sample
just supports the CPU
and the new optimization.
But I tweaked that
using the GPU.
And this one was just for
experiment and just for fun.
That was pretty fun.
And I learned a lot to optimize
the TensorFlow for GPU.
Basically, on Android devices,
performance limiting factor
is mostly coming from
the memory bandwidth
rather than computing itself, so
that reducing memory bandwidth
helped a lot.
For instance, in some
[INAUDIBLE] to the kernel,
it was fetching 32 by
32 by 32 by 4 samples,
just to generate one
output value, which
is a huge amount of data from
the viewpoint of the Compute
Shader.
So memory bandwidth is key,
crucial for the Android
and mobile device optimization.
Anyway, everybody can
tweak TensorFlow code
because it's open-sourced.
It's the beauty of
open source, right?
So now, we can integrate
TensorFlow inference on mobile
quite easily, as I explained.
However, there will still be
challenges in performance.
Even the mobile
device performance
has been increased
significantly.
It has less computing power than
Cloud or desktop counterpart.
Also, it has limited
RAM, which is
a precious resource on mobile.
Let's say, if the application
takes one gigabyte of RAM,
then the application
is highly likely
to be killed by
the system itself
when the application
goes to the background.
That's not a happy
situation, right?
So let's take a look at how
we can optimize TensorFlow
graphics, reducing
memory footprint,
increasing runtime performance,
and improving load time as
well.
This one is the model of
the Inception v3 model.
The model takes around
91 megabytes in storage,
with 25 million parameters.
And the binary size
would take 12 megabytes.
That is huge.
And we have multiple techniques
to optimize the graph,
such as freezing the graph,
using the Graph Transform
Tool, quantization,
memory mapping, et cetera.
Let's go through.
Freezing graph is
one of the load
time optimizations, which
convert variable node
into constant node.
What's a variable node?
In TensorFlow, variable node
starts in a different file.
But the constant
node is included
in the graph def itself.
So moving a variable
into the constant node
can concatenate multiple
files into one file,
like [INAUDIBLE].
That would be a
slight performance
win in mobile and
easier to handle.
To do that, we prepare the
freeze graph dot Python script.
And the graph transform
tool is your friend.
The tool supports various
optimization tasks,
such as stripping unused
nodes for inference.
But it's used only in
the learning phrase
when learning the inference
node, so it's not necessary.
I think that currently, it
would require some minor steps
to determine which
node is the start node
and which node is
the output node.
So the tool requires
both start and output
points specified manually.
Let's talk about quantization.
Neural network operation
requires a bunch
of matrix characterizations,
which means tons of multiply
and add operations.
Current mobile devices are
capable of doing some of them
with specialized hardware.
For instance,
[INAUDIBLE] instruction
in CPU, general-purpose
computing
in GPU, DSP, et cetera.
Roughly, on mobile CPU,
it can perform around
10 to 20 gigabyte
FLOPS in total.
And using GPU, it would achieve
300 to 500 gigaFLOPS or more.
That sounds like a great
number, but is still
based on a desktop
or server environment
so that we want to
perform some optimization.
Quantization is one
of the techniques
to reduce both memory
footprint and computer load.
Usually, TensorFlow takes a
single precision floating value
for input and math, and
also output as well.
As you know, single
precision floating point
takes 32 bits each.
But we found that we can reduce
the precision to 16 bits, 8
bits, or even less while
keeping a good result,
just because our
learning process involves
some noise by nature.
And adding some extra
noises wouldn't matter much.
So quantized weight
is the optimization
for storage size, which
reduces the precision
of the constant node
in the graph file.
But please note that with the
quantized weight optimization,
the value will be
expanded on memory when
the graph is loaded.
So we have another optimization.
We can call it the
quantized calculations.
With the quantized
calculations, we
can reduce computing precision
by using the quantized value
directory.
This one is good for
first memory bandwidth,
which is a limiting
factor in mobile devices.
Also, hardware can handle
these precision values faster
than single precision
floating values.
But we still have an open issue.
To do the quantized
calculation, we
need the maximum value
and the minimum value
that specify the range
of the quantized values.
We still don't have a
great solution for that.
It's still manual.
But active research is going on
so that hopefully, this issue
will be resolved pretty soon.
This one is an example of how
quantized characterization
optimization works
in TensorFlow.
TensorFlow has some operations
that support quantization.
For instance,
convolution to the matrix
multiply [INAUDIBLE], et cetera.
We think that's
good enough to cover
most of inference scenarios.
However, we still don't have
order of operations quantized
yet, so that we need to quantize
the value and dequantize value
output right before
and after each node.
And the graph transform
tool analyzes parts
of each graph node.
And sometimes, we can reduce
unnecessary quantized and
dequantized values.
Memory mapping is yet another
optimization for loading time.
With this optimization,
the model file
is converted and can
be mapped directly
using the memmap API,
which could be slightly
performance optimization on
some Linux-based operating
systems like Android.
Another one is reducing
executable size.
That's an important
topic in mobile
as well, because
on mobile devices,
executable package size is
limited to a specific size--
for instance, 100
megabytes for Android,
including binary, graphics,
and any other resources.
By default, a mobile device
supports multiple selected
operations that are
mostly good enough
to cover inference operations,
but ops used learning process
is missing.
So if you want to do the
learning on a mobile device,
you need to register
extra operations.
Also, if your graph
wouldn't require
some preregistered
operations, you
would also remove some of them.
To do that, you can do
selective registration.
So for instance,
for Inception v3,
by doing the selective
registration,
the original binary
size was 12 megabytes.
And after the
optimization, it can
be reduced to 1.5 megabytes.
Note that this optimization
requires rebuilding the shared
object in your local.
So you would need to construct
the build environment as well.
So with these optimizations,
Inception v3 graph
now becomes 23 megabytes
and 1.5 megabytes
in binary size, which
is 75% smaller now.
Let's get back to Kazu.
KAZ SATO: Thank you, Hak.
So as Hak mentioned,
there are so many--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
As Hak mentioned, there
are so many tips and tricks
to optimize your
TensorFlow model
to squeeze into an Android
mobile application.
And that is what you
can do right now.
These techniques are
available right now.
But now, I'd like to
discuss a little bit
about the new technologies
coming in the near future,
such as TensorFlow Lite and
Android Neural Network API.
What is NNAPI?
It's a new API for neural
network processings
inside Android, and that will be
added to the Android framework.
And the purpose of
adding a new API
is to encapsulate and
have an abstraction
layer for the hardware
accelerators such as GPU, DSP,
and ISP.
And modern smartphones have such
a powerful computing resource
other than CPU,
such as GPU or DSP.
Especially the DSP
is designed to do
a massive amount of the matrix
and vector calculations,
so it's much faster to
use DSP or GPUs to do
the neural networks inference
on it, rather than using a CPU.
But right now, if
you want to do that,
you have to go directly
into the library provided
by the hardware vendors
and build some binaries
by yourself.
It's a tedious task.
And also, it's not portable.
So instead, we'll be providing a
standard API so that developers
don't have to be aware of any
of the hardware accelerators
from each individual vendor.
On top of the
Neural Network API,
we will be providing
TensorFlow Lite.
That will be a new
TensorFlow runtime
optimized for mobile and
embedded applications.
So TensorFlow Lite is designed
for smart and compact mobile
or embedded applications.
And also, it is designed to
be combined with the Android
NNAPI.
So all you have
to do is to build
your model with TensorFlow
Lite, and that's it.
Eventually, you will be
getting all the benefits
you could get from
the Android NNAPI,
such as the hardware
acceleration.
That will be coming as an open
source in the near future,
so stay tuned.
And if you're interested in
these new coming technologies,
please take a photograph
of this QR code,
so that you can join our
survey for the ML on Android,
where you can give your
feedback or requests
for the new products.
OK, thank you.
So lastly, I'd like to show
some very interesting and fun
real-world applications
built with TensorFlow
on mobile and embedded systems.
The first application is running
on the Raspberry Pi, built
by a Japanese cucumber farmer.
Actually, I myself
took this photograph.
I went there to the cucumber
farm and took this photograph.
And they have, you can see--
oh, sorry.
[CHUCKLE] There's no pointer.
So you have the one
person in the middle.
He's [INAUDIBLE].
He started helping with
cucumber farming two years ago.
And he found out that sorting
cucumbers into correct classes
is the most tedious task.
His mother spent
eight hours a day
classifying each cucumber based
on its shape, length, or color,
into nine different
classes, and he really
didn't want to help her.
So instead, he
downloaded TensorFlow
and built his own
cucumber sorter.
[APPLAUSE]
So what he did is he
took 9,000 photographs
of the different
cucumbers, and put
the labels classified
by his mother,
and trained the TensorFlow
model by himself.
And he built the sorter robotics
by himself, by spending $1,500.
And the TensorFlow model is
running on the Raspberry Pi
to detect the cucumbers
put on the plate.
And it can classify cucumbers
into nine different classes,
based on its shape and colors.
And this is a system
diagram of the systems.
So it has three parts.
The Arduino Micro is used
for controlling the servers
and models.
And Raspberry Pi has a camera to
take a picture of the cucumbers
on the plate.
And it runs a very small
TensorFlow model on it.
And this is actually
a very great example
of how you can split
the tasks, the work
load for machine learning into
an edge device and cloud part.
Because he found out running
the whole set of the TensorFlow
model inside the Raspberry
Pi is too heavyweight.
So he decided to split
it into two tasks.
So the TensorFlow model
running on Raspberry Pi only
detects whether there's a
cucumber on the plate or not.
And only when it detects
there's a cucumber on the plate,
it sends the picture
to the server,
where he has a more
powerful TensorFlow
model that can classify
the cucumber into nine
different classes.
Let's take a look at another
interesting application
running on Android and iOS,
that is the Gymnastic Exercise
Scorer.
What is that?
Actually, every Japanese
knows the exercise
called radio exercise, because
we have a national radio
broadcasting network.
They play the same exercise
music at the same time
every morning.
And tens of millions
of Japanese people
are doing the same
exercise every morning.
Did you know that?
[LAUGHTER]
This application
is designed to--
we call it the
scorer-- so how well
you have been doing your
exercise with the music.
And to capture the motions
with the motion sensor,
they have used TensorFlow.
And they were able to train
the TensorFlow model to capture
and extract the patterns
or features from the data
from the motion
sensors, so that it
is able to evaluate the
motions made by the human hand.
And they also built their
own TensorFlow compiler
so that they were able
to apply the techniques
such as the quantization
or approximations.
And they were able to
reduce the TensorFlow
model from tens of megabytes
into a few megabytes.
So that was the key technology
to build the production quality
Android and iOS applications
with the TensorFlow power.
Let's take a look at the live
demonstration of the Exercise
Scorer.
So can I switch to here?
This is the application
where you can choose
the various kinds of exercises.
And I'll be playing
the most standard one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this is the music.
[LAUGHTER]
[JAPANESE SPEECH FROM EXERCISE
SCORER]
[APPLAUSE]
Am I doing all right?
So just like that--
so let's stop.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC STOPS ABRUPTLY]
It's enough.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, the TensorFlow
model is trying
to evaluate how well you
have done this exercise.
And you can see
the bar chart here.
That is the variation
by the TensorFlow
model inside this application.
It's a real thing.
OK?
Go back to the slide.
That was the thing
we wanted to show.
In this session, we have
learned many things, including
yet another weird
thing from Japan,
and then some
optimization techniques
for building
TensorFlow applications
with the production quality
Android and iOS applications.
And if you're interested,
please go to TensorFlow.org,
where you can have lots of
getting-started materials.
And there are some
of the good codelabs
on the codelab website.
Thank you so much.
HAK MATSUDA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]